enjoying the Great Outdoors can be a
huge challenge for people with impaired
mobility this morning our series pushing
the limits looks at a new program
offering them a front row seat to places
that used to be Out Of Reach all-terrain
Georgia an initiative led by a quadruple
amputee Amy Copeland recently introduced
a fleet of wheelchairs specially
equipped to navigate rugged terrain it's
making parks and trails more accessible
and it's all free of charge Mark
Strassman was there as one man took
controls for the first time to bond with
his family and mother nature in a whole
new way
a walk in the woods in search of
Nature's Glory fresh air a light wintry
Breeze the sun's warmth seems so simple
but not for Mario Sanchez who's now 41.
since he was two muscular dystrophy has
been telling him no when you're going
down a hill or up a hill you want to
make sure you're down to a one or two
okay that's about to change with this
motorized all-terrain wheelchair part of
a new Georgia program championed by Amy
Copeland clean fresh air sunlight it is
a game changer it's a life changer after
a 2012 ziplining accident gaster calf
Copeland contracted a freak flesh-eating
bacterial infection to save her life
doctors amputated both her hands her
right foot and her entire left leg
someone so active no longer able to walk
she was 24. I gave myself a nice pity
party I can only do that for so long you
were thinking this is not the way I'm
going to spend my life as sad as I was I
can only be sad that long before I get
very bored and realize that I need to be
outside
her foundation pushed the state for
years to allow these all-terrain
wheelchairs to create moments like this
it is a freeing experience being out in
the middle of the woods with the sun on
your face and debris and the trees and
the birds Melanie Dunn a double amputee
and assistant director at Copeland's
Foundation says the response to all
terrain Georgia has been phenomenal just
imagine that you can never walk again
and that's what it's like to be in a
wheelchair and the person that is in
this chair all of a sudden is just
Blown Away
on the edge of Georgia's Sweetwater
Creek State Park just west of Atlanta
Mario Sanchez heads out for a family
outing into the woods we go the parks
path has uneven terrain rocks branches
occasional standing water for him all
the usual deal breakers I'll put it up
to three but Sanchez suddenly is a half
mile deep in the woods immersed in its
Wonder that's so cool
it really handles good for the first
time in his life it's a blast it really
is liberating very very liberating just
to be able to go out with them and not
have to think about you know is is there
pavement or what am I going to do while
you guys are out hiking or whatever a
family first too I mean it sounds like
it was a kick for him but it's a kick
for you to watch him it never occurred
to me we would be here doing this like
it's so cool cool the programs available
in 11 Georgia State Parks and Wildlife
preserves and it's free introducing
nature to some reconnecting nature to
others first time I got in one of these
chairs it was like running again it was
a feeling like I can't explain it's like
they've entered another dimension
they've gone through a portal to peace
and serenity and beauty and awe and
Discovery Sanchez found himself on a
path he had never traveled what a
difference that's cool for CBS mornings
Mark Strassman Lithia Springs Georgia
what an incredible story mark thank you
very much